[Musique]
bonjour je lis ça lui gagné une seconde
a suffi de trier les caramels que j'ai
fait tomber par erreur dans les bonbons
fruits
tu en veux un os non merci tu sais
depuis que je suis au régime je ne mange
plus qu'une seule dragées au poivre par
jour et ben alors il faut aller de
servir au magasin de farces et attrapes
donc pourquoi tu fais un régime mais
c'est monsieur du snob
il m'a dit que j'étais un gros monstre
un monstre je veux bien mais gros ça je
ne supporte pas pour casimir tu dois
mourir de faim dis moi tu n'as pas vu
monsieur campagne annoncée pour lui
toutes ces lacs
oui c'est mon courrier du jour est
évident qu'à ses meilleurs arrêts
courrier le ministre
oui oui oui j'attends le facteur bilan
comment va-t-on régime amincissant même
très bien j'aime écrire un beau à voir
enfin peut-être mais dis donc tu m'as
l'air bien chargé et avec toutes ces
lettres qui doit être impatient et
qu'est ce que c'est que ce deal france à
ça c'est un secret casini allait se voir
juste le titre je te dis que c'est un
secret ça ne me regarde pas c'est
vraiment de secrets oui tu ne dois
absolument pas savoir ce qui est écrit
dans ce livre à et bien moi j'ai quand
même une petite idée sur le sujet mais
on parle ce livre a well as et laquelle
eh bien ça ne parlait pas un peu de
nourriture dans un parent de nourriture
mais pas du tout tu sais parfaitement
que je suis au régime
bonjour à tous nos joueurs pas besoin de
dire qu'il fait beau temps on prendrait
j'ai toujours du soleil dans nos enfants
ouais à casimir je suis bien content tu
te sers du catalogue que je t'ai donné à
c'est un formidable reçoit dont j'ai
fait cadeau à casimir ne vous embête et
vous en a sûrement des gens rabâcher les
oreilles à leo messi messi mais nous il
nous a rien dit facteur de la république
nous dit que tu es si vous êtes tous dit
moi je ne pas recommencer
mais voyez vous rien que le nom le nom
il aura la bouche au catalogue
gastronomie de france
kazim est en vie dont je croyais que ton
livre ne parlait pas de nourriture
tu sais ce que c'est que la gastronomie
ouais et alors eh bien j'aimerais que tu
me le dise et bien c'est là c'est la
science des choses qui se mange et je ne
voulais pas nous en parler à cause de
ton original 1 600 pourriez bien je
voudrais maigrir mais je ne peux pas me
passer de manger tu en veux pas casimir
situe maigrissait plus serait horrible
c'est vrai oui alors je peux arrêter de
faire mon régime exactement bon écoutez
ça me fait penser j'ai quelque chose à
faire il faut que je parte tout de suite
8 au 10 mars courant même ces lettres a
posté un bon moment mercedes et casino à
bâle et à rester chez moi pas des normes
ou bulgares qui m'attend à la comme je
ne suis plus au régime
aux yeux de m 4 saucisses je vais
pouvoir mettre si françois cazis mir
kazemi
il n'a mis que les adresses incomplètes
regarder elles sont toutes pareilles il
manque un achat qu'une le nom de la
ville
vous savez pas facteur julie du premier
crayon pour compléter les enveloppes
d'accord
les enfants vous venez venez faire un
jeu
installez-vous dans l'herbe vous êtes
bien là dans les enfants vous allez nous
aider en complétant les enveloppes que
casimir envoie en nous donnant le nom de
la ville correspondant à chaque
spécialité facteurs la première bombe
alors la première monsieur le plus grand
fabricant de bouillabaisse à socke et
marseille
tout de suite ça jaillit l'or julie lui
marc marseille ensuite peur monsieur le
plus grand fabricant de nougat je suis
le plus grand fabricant de nougat sophie
harent et là sur le bout de la langue
mont terri nahas et myriam julie tu
notes vous aviez trouvé les cheveux
montélimar du nougat parfait on continue
les chiots le plus grand fabricant de
cassoulet
[Musique]
dans quelle ville cassoulet le facteur
doit le savoir lui alors
et chez vous le cassoulet et je vous le
dis moi c'est toulouse
julie qu'il savait myriam ensuite facta
ensuite monsieur le plus grand fabricant
du betis de beat it est ce que c'est que
la bêtise qu'est ce que c'est
qu'est ce que samir y sommes ce sont des
bons dos et on y fabrique dans quelle
ville
personne ne sait gérard t71 et vous chez
vous vous savez à j'entends la réponse
cambrai cambrai c'est ça la dynamique
andré joly à monsieur le plus grand
fabricant de proue nom a pris dans un
jeu tout le monde a répondu à jeun
monsieur le plus grand fabricant de
rillettes les rillettes
le mans se ferait bien mais on n'a pas
le temps de respirer ça fuse la dernière
secteur lavalas dernière à monsieur le
plus grand fabricant de chocolat à deux
coups vous savez est ici dans l'île aux
enfants
on connaît la réponse très sophistiqué
note julie strasbourg à un facteur on
arrête encore là casimir casimir casimir
ne t'inquiète pas nous avons complété
toutes les angles s'est tous mis et je
n'ai plus qu'à les emporter mais ça ne
m'intéresse plus du tout plu du tout
mais voilà mais quel cynisme états unis
en irak
mais qu'est-ce qui tape mais qu'est ce
qui t'arrive d'être qui je pus commandes
est plein de bonnes choses je me suis
rendu compte que le meilleur plat du
monde c'était le gloubiboulga alors je
n'ai vraiment plus besoin des autres
[Musique]